[Music]
hello there free to play video games can
be a bit of a minefield for every great
game we see we get at least seven which
aren't so great so i thought i'd show
you 10 games that look to be excellent
free-to-play experiences for you and
your friends some games are coming out
this summer others are due in 2023 if
you'd like me to cover any of these in
detail please let me know in the
comments now let's do this
coming this summer is disney speedstorm
imagine a cross-platform mario kart
starring characters from disney and
pixar sounds pretty good right each of
the tracks is based on iconic locations
from the animated movies and tv shows
and the roster is absolutely packed
mickey can race sully from monsters inc
captain jack sparrow can go up against
donald duck it's weird in the best kind
of way like mario kart the characters
have slightly different stats but that's
where speedstorm pivots as each racer
has their own specific skills and
abilities and we've seen a few ultimate
abilities too each new season will bring
new tracks and new characters which will
likely be where we start paying for
content to my surprise split screen
couch co-op is confirmed and cross play
is here too on playstation xbox switch
pc and mobile summer can't come soon
enough
[Music]
as we're already comparing these new
games to nintendo products let's
continue back in december i showed you
multiverses a two on two platform
fighter which takes on the smash bros
formula multiverses is due to release
any moment now on playstation xbox and
pc and lets us choose to fight with a
host of characters from warner brothers
owned franchises this means batman can
fight shaggy from scooby-doo on release
there will be at least 13 playable
characters with more coming regularly to
keep the meta changing and players on
their toes if multiverses is successful
we can expect to see mortal kombat
characters joining the fight or even
lord of the rings alumni each character
has their own abilities and the synergy
between each pair is important or if you
don't want to play with a teammate it
can be a free-for-all instead
multiverses is releasing this year it
could be releasing any minute now i'll
keep you updated
[Music]
have a look-see at spine a team-based
action game set in this dystopian
technology-filled world spine technology
turned standard human beings into super
beings with improved reflexes we are
told that martial arts movies have
inspired the melee focused combat and
the gun-fu seen in films like the matrix
is implemented throughout so dodging
bullets looks to be a real option here
before getting up close and personal
with a katana in hand the devs want the
game to feel like a movie as well as a
competitive pvp experience spine has
been confirmed for ps5 xbox series pc
and mobile we'll find out more in late
2022 cyberpunk gunfu and samurais spine
could be a massive hit
[Music]
a game i'm watching and hoping to be
great is exo mecca a first-person
shooter where futuristic soldiers do
battle on a newly found untouched planet
the gun play looks solid and the sheer
breadth of things we've seen is just wow
underwater caves for flanking maneuvers
so many vehicles to drive like tanks and
helicopters oh and like the name
suggests this freaking mechs here it'll
be like being in the scene from the
transformers movie originally this was
only planned for pc but it's now coming
to xbox and there are reports of ps5 too
but i don't trust those sources right
now the release date for exomecha has
already been pushed back a few times it
was due out last month it appears that
further funding is allowing the team to
create a bigger game than we first saw
so now we play the waiting game a
release date is due my guess is this
free-to-play game will be coming in 2023
[Music]
another free game to look out for in the
summer is gundam evolution i know
there's been some questionable gundam
games in the past but from the people
who've played the beta so far it's
actually fun gundam evolution is a six
on six hero shooter the feedback
suggests evolution is heavily inspired
by overwatch from the hud to the map
layout and the skills of each unit each
gundam has a different health pool dash
limit and preferred range of combat and
on release three game modes are
confirmed point capture domination and
destruction i'll tell you more about
those when the game releases in a month
or two like usual it's another
cross-platform release on ps4 ps5 all
the xboxes and pc as well
starting this summer another
free-to-play disney game is coming to
take over your life disney dreamlight
valley basically over time all the
disney characters have forgotten about
each other and the world they live in
that's where you rock up and bring
everyone back together it appears that
dreamlike valley is a cross between a
typical adventure game with quests and
something like the sims or animal
crossing we haven't seen any gameplay
mechanics just yet but if you want to
sign up to be a founder or if you have
xbox game pass you'll be the first to
play in july with the full release
scheduled for 2023. it's going to be on
every platform from playstation to
android from switch to ios i just hope
they don't make me collect turnips like
animal crossing that was too hardcore
[Music]
i started this video by showing you a
cart racing game set to be big well it
turns out that that space is quite
competitive thanks to cart rider drift
just like disney's speedstorm the vibe
is most definitely mario kart but unlike
speedstorm kart rider is much more
closer to the iconic cart races of the
past power-ups can be found on the road
and shortcuts play an important part to
stay competitive especially on harder
settings drift is going all out on
customization and making that the center
of their business plan as the other kart
racer is scheduled for summer it's
likely that cartwright adrift will
release before that to try and maximise
their time in the sun if you want to
play now you can sign up for it or you
can wait for the full release set for
the summer on ps4 ps5 xbox and pc
[Music]
my most anticipated free-to-play game of
2022 is arc raiders a co-operative
third-person shooter in which we are a
group of raiders who must fight back
against the onslaught of ark a ruthless
machine threat descending from space
we'll be scavenging the ruins of a
forgotten world to somehow find a way to
outsmart our new enemies celeste is the
face of the game someone who lost
everything to ark and then became a
resistance fighter the game is also
based on a book of the same name in
march the play testing for the full game
began which if all goes well should see
arc raiders pop up again soon with a
release date until then all we know is
that it's coming in 2022 on ps5 xbox
series and pc when epic games closed
down paragon in favour of fortnite there
was a bunch of that community left with
nothing to play that's where over prime
comes in a moba an online battle arena
that takes inspiration from dota league
of legends and paragon over prime is
actually already out on pc right now but
the real reason i'm including it in this
video is due to this footage the
overprime team are currently working on
a console port here it is on the ps5 dev
kit being used to play a full match
no console release date just yet 2022
maybe
and finally for game 10 it's another
title which was due to release earlier
this year but at the very last second in
february it was pulled and now once
again we are waiting a new release date
all we know for certain is it's coming
in 2022. this is rumble verse a battle
royale game but guns are replaced with
wrestling moves 40 players crash down
into the city as the usual storm circles
push everyone closer and closer together
until only one is left standing it
doesn't take itself too seriously at all
rumble verse is all about customization
and looking however you want there is a
crazy amount of flexibility from skin
color body shape and hairstyles right
down to elbow pads and the color of your
underwear
which we all know is very important i
played a few of the rumble verse tests
and it was certainly lacking something
which made you want to come back for
game after game after game but if they
do find the trigger to make people want
to play constantly i believe rumble
verse will be huge and it has the
backing of epic games if rumble verse
interests you be sure to check back next
month because i have a full breakdown
coming so there we have it 10
free-to-play games that i believe are
worth your time releasing between now
and summer next year thank you very much
for watching to the end i'm adam you're
awesome it's been a pleasure i'll see
you next time
[Music]